everyone this is kevin from the chess
website comm and today we are in game 10
of the 2016 World Chess Championship so
far the last few games have been
extremely exciting game number 8 is when
Magnus Carlsen actually playing the
white pieces lost to circuit cardiac in
and then the last game Sergey yakin
really really strong game potentially
could have found a victory in that game
but they did have a drawl so with three
games remaining Magnus Carlsen is going
to be applying the white pieces in two
of them game 10 and then game 12 and
expecting fireworks from him he knows
that he needs at least a victory to
continue on to potentially tiebreakers
on November 30th which is actually his
birthday so he's got to try something
different can't try the same openings
that we've done before so we'll go ahead
and jump into game number 10 Magnus
Carlsen starts out pawn to e4 pawn e5
Knight f3 knight c6 Bishop to b5 and
then Knight to f6 so this is the Berlin
defense from Sergei cata yak and
something as we've talked about many
times before Magnus Carlsen extremely
familiar with it's one of his favourite
defenses against the Rye Lopez and he
tries two different variations we
haven't seen this for a while from
Magnus Carlson's pawn to d3 and this is
a variation that we actually saw you
know back in Sochi when he was playing
vision on a couple years ago for the
World Chess Championship after Bishop to
c5 in that particular thing we saw
castle on the Kings side he decides to
change it up a little bit and play pawn
to c3 so he's trying to take his
opponent out of book theory very early
on it if people always ask me what's
what kind of differentiates a
grandmaster from a high-level top player
and one of those is their understanding
of opening theory they've if there's a
high level game that's been played with
a certain line they've probably studied
and they're probably pretty familiar
with it so Magnus Carlsen is trying to
get his opponent out of theory as fast
as possible to make him start using up
some of some of his time because early
on they don't use much time on some of
these openings so that's kind of what
management recognizes he needs to do
because cardiac connects tremely well on
defense so we see continued castle on
the Kings side
Bishop to g5 getting the dark spread
bishop it involved into the game pawn to
h6 forcing the bishop back here to h4
Bishop comes back here to b7 just
protecting this night being pinned down
castle on the Kings side upon to d6 are
solidifying the pawn chain so Carr yakin
so far doing a pretty good job of
defending against this Berlin defense
kind of an anti Berlin attack from
Magnus Carlsen here not here to d2
Knight to h5 looking to come to the f4
square right here and then the bishop
decides to go ahead and take here we do
see in exchange and then Knight to c4
now this is kind of holding down this
fort sometimes you you'll even want to
see pawn here to h3 to protect the
bishop coming down here to g4 but
instead says okay yeah I could play pawn
to h3 but that's not really going to
stop this Knight to f4 which is really
what karyakin wants to be doing then
it's somewhat of a wasted move you may
not even see the bishop coming down here
Bishop may come to something like six to
kind of stop any threat of this light
square Bishop attacking sometimes when
you have your pawn structures on the
dark squares from black you do want to
stop your opponent from really attacking
this f7 square so decides to go ahead
and not worry about a pawn to h3 move
and instead go for more of a pawn to c4
and then bring it back over here - III
potentially or maybe start an attack on
the Queen side of the board
so carjacking comes down Knight to f4 s
we kind of thought we'd salt after
Knight here to h5 med over here to e3
and then Queen to f6 pawn to g3 forcing
and the knight to move Knight over here
to h3 forcing the King to move and then
we see the knight come back here to e7
so our karyakin decides he's not really
looking to trade off material right now
he wants to kind of maneuver his pieces
over to the Kings side the board
recognizing that he could potentially
have a strong attack or just a finned
against Magnus Carlson's attack that he
has to assume is going to be coming in
this game the Bishop to c4 and something
I thought we might see from Magnus cross
anytime your opponent
it takes their pieces away from some
piece of the board that's very important
in the early game it's usually going to
be the center of the board so you see
this night over here on h3 now
protecting the center you see the knight
here was protecting it with night here
on c6 but as soon as it comes back here
to e7 there there's kind of an opening
here so I thought we may see pawn to d4
maybe start to attack the center of the
board and then maybe you know e six
trying to just get Y squared bishop
involved into the game pawn to d4
probably which what we see here bishop
back here kind of wasting a move Queen
to e2 just completing development here
but you can see starting to choke off
some of the squares that car yeah can
can go to thought Mayas seen it in the
game we did not instead we saw the
bishop come here to c4 starting to
attack this long light square diagonal
pawn to c6 getting ready to put forward
if he needs to try to control these
light squares in the start of the board
Bishop back here to b3 Knight to g6
Queen d2 completing development pawn to
a5 and you see this elias's one side
plays you know pawn to a4 or pawn to a5
from black other side just Amelia says
okay I want you to put too much pressure
on this side of the board I don't have
to worry about that so pawn to a4 Bishop
to e6 light square Bishop is not doing
too much on board right now so decides
okay there's a lot of pressure going on
with your light square bishop so let's
just go ahead and trade that off so
don't have to worry about too much pawn
recaptures on e6 this position actually
like cardiac can set up a little bit
better his Knights aren't really playing
together all that well currently but
that the pawn structure right here from
white does allow you know a knight to
eventually sneak in an attack he does
have there's no ponds that have come off
the board but karyakin does have a
semi-open file for his rooks and his
Queens to tart to really put pressure on
this this F file can it can get more
involvement to the game than magnetic
Carlson's recovered here on a1 so all in
all that there's a lot of material that
can still come off the board we don't
really know what the pawn structure is
going to look like it that the endgame
so both sides have really strong chances
if I were just kind of judging this
scenario right here does kind of look
like kuryakin's did a good job defending
it maybe
has some really strong attacking chances
now magnus carlsen plays a knight to d2
and here's kind of a very critical spot
in this particular game and after this
game they had the press conference and
as we've we've talked about before if
you haven't seen these conferences they
usually bring up different positions and
just say you know what were your
thoughts on here did you consider this
line did you think about this strategy
in one thing they really talked about
cardiac and in this position is he kind
of had a drawl Sergei karyakin would
snap high-five his opponent if he can
have a drawl at this moment recognized
Magnus Carlsen he needs a win so if
karyakin can just to fin and have a
drawl especially the last two times at
karyakin has the black pieces that would
be a phenomenal result for him and what
they kind of asked him was you know why
didn't you go after Knight to f2 and he
was kind of going through some of the
situations he did not necessarily see
that it was a horse draw so Knight to f2
we see King to g2 Knight to h4 check
gets a little tricky if the pawn were to
take because then you just have Queen
over here to g6 why it's going to be
down upon a material the pawn structure
is completely just destroyed over here
on the Kings side for Magnus Carlsen
this would be bad but it let's say the
pot or the King comes back here to g1
then pawn to h3 and then we do see a
perpetual check here and this would be a
a drawn game now the situation that
karyakin said that he was looking at was
the king to g1 and then after h3 check
King up here to g2 and he did not think
about the fact that his knight could
come to f4 and fork this Queen here now
if the pawn were to take the knight
comes here and there is going to be f4
now even if the rook comes up in
captures you know that's going to be
okay take that rook have double rookie
and a queen that's going to be in game
that karyakin should be able to to go on
and win if nothing else draw very very
easy
all I don't think magnus carlsen would
have allowed this position to happen is
everyone kind of said you know if you
would have played night 2 f2 it probably
just would have been a perpetual check
Kuryakin said he did miss that in the
game he actually didn't think about it
too long which is kind of surprising it
was pawn to d5 so kind of the the
situation rose as we talked about on the
opposite side but once this Knight was
no longer defending the sin of the board
Kuryakin decided to go ahead and strike
try to have some exchange on board so he
no longer has the double pawns here on
the e-file but after Queen to h5 and
that comes back here to g5 so taking
away some of that pressure he could have
even if he wanted to take it with his
knight here I have to would have
probably been some sort of repetition is
well King here to g2 Queen up here to f7
getting ready for the night to come down
to F war check and a discovered attack
on this Queen as well so I did probably
missed another forced drawl as well but
Knight comes back here to g5 taking away
some of that pressure from Magnus
Carlsen pawn up here h4 now Knight sit
down here to f3 we could to exchange on
board that's exactly what we see Queen
comes down on f3 check Queen has had to
go ahead and take ruk takes on f3 so all
know this is pretty good I think for
karyakin starting to exchange material
on board King to g2 forcing the brooke
back here to f7 rook to e1 and this is
interesting in the game Magnus Carlsen
actually touched his pawn here on f2
before he moved I was very slight but it
was very clear if you saw the video he
touched his pawn if he would play pawn
to f3 it still would have been okay I
don't I don't think the position is all
that terrible but he actually did touch
it now they probably should have forced
him to move the pawn but it was so quick
not rook here to it II won they didn't
really decide to to make him change that
pawn to h5 Knight back here to f1
getting ready to maneuver that a little
bit different King to f8 night here to
d2 King to e7 so now that the queens are
off the board and there's only one minor
you can really start to use your king
involvement to the game and have that be
a major player for your attack on the
board magnus carlsen plays rook to e2
King up here to d6 Knight to f3 just
saying hey I can have a nice little
outpost here on g5 depending on where
you go eventually I can take this pawn
here on e5 since it's not being
protected by any pawns right now just
material depending on where you go could
have that on board Knight to g5 first
nice little outpost move
we're cover here to e1 rook to e8 then
back here to f3 so both sides just
moving a little bit seeing what's going
to happen here and then Knights - AJ in
this this kind of always has my spidey
senses going off a little bit what once
someone's Knight goes completely away
from where the action is I feel like
there's going to be something crazy
happens in the board Magnus Carlsen
decides to go ahead and start pushing in
the center of the board no reason to
start you know posturing around here
with your other pieces this Knights not
involved okay let's start to push a pawn
to d4 we do see an exchange aboard that
was actually the first ponds that have
come off the board which is kind of
crazy you know we're 35 moves in that's
the first time we see pawns coming off
the board pawn here to g6 and then rook
up here to ithi routing Reds come to f3
and then up here to f6 nice little
square you know you're attacking this e
6 square that you have protection from
your knight you're also attacking this
pond right here the knight on H a does
not want to stay on AJ protecting this
pawn so nice little combination magnus
carlsen is looking to do and he wants to
keep Kuryakin on his back foot he wants
him continue to defend there's a lot of
game left and so I just wants to make
sure that he is the aggressor and he's
putting pressure on his opponent Knight
to f7 upon up here to e5 check forces of
the King to come back rook here to f3 s
we talked about Knight to h6 so Kari I
can do a good job of maneuvering the
knight out of trouble there although he
has used quite a bit of moves for this
Knight rook up here to f6 we kind of
talked about this earlier rook to g7
protecting this pawn here on g6 punt up
here to be forward we do
seeing exchange on board night here 2g8
rook back here to f3 recognizing okay
right now at least karyakin has all his
material just holding down these ponds
so I can't really do anything so decides
to go ahead and focus over here on the
Queen side of the board Knight to h6
upon up here to a4 so starts to see a
little bit of weakness says okay if your
rooks
and your Neider over here I can start to
maneuver over to the Queen side and
start to really push put a lot of
pressure on that side very very quickly
Kuryakin Knight tier to f5 and this is
an outpost that really stops this rook
from doing too much more as far as
getting behind enemy lines on this side
of the board Knight over here to b3 does
not want to exchange off his Knights
right now King to f7 recognizing needs
to start to move over on the Queen side
start to protect that a little bit
Knight to c5 so this is a much better
square for this Knight still holding
down putting pressure on this pawn on e6
but also stop some of the the squares
that the King here on the Queen side the
board could start to get too and also
adding pressure on the pawn here on b7
as well came back here to b8 recover
here to be one so getting all that
pressure over on the Queen side of the
board King to a7 a rook to d3 just
stopping it the Knights going to be
coming here to d4 doesn't want to have
to worry about that at all rook here to
c7 work over here to a three-night to a
d4 says okay now that the rooks are not
really holding down the fort here I'm
going to go ahead and bring my knight
but although this is a great square very
centrally located it's kind of just
playing by itself here can't really do
too much so after rook here to d1 the
knight does come back King up here to h3
Knight back here to h6 pawn to f3 so
wants to stop some of these squares that
the knight can come to we are currently
on move 51 they do get extra time after
move 60 so a lot of times in this
position even before you get to 40 where
they get a lot more time you'll start to
see slowly pieces moving around trying
to find a little edge here and there but
they like to get that that
extra time and then really start to
think a little bit deeper in some of
their moves work here to f7 rook up here
to d4 Knight to f5 forcing the rook back
here to d2 rook takes seven I'll work
here to b3 rookie seven rook here to d3
rook up here to 88 and then rook down
here to be one and this was the most
critical time in this game so far beyond
that night - f2 which car yeah can you
know could have had a draw here but
after rook two to be one word move 56
both sides not really at least on board
it looks like doing anything too crazy
in karyakin said in this moment he said
hey yeah my opponents just kind of been
moving his rooks back and forth it
seemed like he was trying to get to move
60 which is only four moves from now
said I've been doing a pretty good job
of defending these positions so far I
didn't think he was really up to
anything when he played rook through u1
I thought it was somewhat innocent to be
honest and he played rook 287
unfortunately for him he said afterwards
I recognized as soon as he played pawn
to b5 that I had made a huge mistake
here on h7 he's I didn't I didn't
realize that rook to b1 he wanted to
push right away and that was kind of
kind of where he fell flat instead of
the rook coming to h7 you know could
have played rook over here to c8 trying
to protect the Queen side of the board
and said he played rook to h7 which
really left his Queen side of the board
under attack that would be very
difficult to hold on to so upon to b5
pawn recaptures rook to b5 is
interesting if when you heard from
Magnus Carlsen in the press conference
he said yeah I was kind of planning that
pawn to b5 for a long time at the end of
the game and so it's interesting to see
how even before move 60 is they kind of
maneuver pieces around Magnus Carlsen
was just waiting for that right
opportunity to play pawn to b5 to try to
break through over here on the Queen
side he has a lot of material on the
Queen side of the board we can start to
add a lot of pressure to his opponent
definitely not a automatic win
but madness Carson has a huge advantage
he can start to really attack his
opponent on board in previous games that
we seen so far in this tournament as
Carlson's kind of squandered some
opportunities but recognizing that he no
longer has that option here if he
squanders another opportunity that could
be the world championship so upon here
to d3 a rook appear to be six starting
to put pressure on these ponds we're
gonna be here to c6 or c7 a knight up
here to e6 rook down here a knight down
here to f4 rook over here to c6 in the
Knight to d5
I thought we actually may have seen you
know something different maybe the rook
take on g6 and then if hey the rooks
going to take here you know we could
take back on d3 but decides to instead
play a knight up here to d5 forking both
the rooks the works kind of forced to
come here in exchange Knight up here to
c7 kingdom be eight died down here to b5
attacking this pawn king over here to c8
rook to g6 so some material comes off
the board both sides have a passed pawn
Magnus Carlsen is up a pawn in material
the King is a little bit more exposed
for kuryakin so while the advantage is a
not huge Magnus Carlsen definitely has a
winning in game in sight so it's all
about if he can actually turn this into
a victory skal synge continues with
Kings to g2 attacking the rook rook
comes over here to be three Knight up
here to c6 attacking the king and the
knight Knight decides to go ahead yeah I
pretty much have to take it here so rook
here to d6 attacking the pawn the rook
comes over here to e5 attacking this
pawn as well it's kind of hard for both
sides of the board to really hold on to
material right here and he could have
even tried a king to c7 instead of bring
his rook over here after a rook to e3
upon up here to e6 King to c7 it's
difficult because let's say you know
pawn to d3 then all of a sudden King
over here to f2 very difficult to hold
on you know rook to e2 okay fine King up
here to f3
and then what is black really do if he
pushes his pawn then the rooks going to
fall so he's just gonna have to play
something like King here to c7 but then
his pawn Falls all its it's just kind of
awkward for him so decides to go ahead
and not worry about pushing his own pond
besides going to play King to c7 now and
the pawns are gonna have to come off the
board same thing as we talked about with
you know car yak and not being able to
protect that pawn Magnus Carlsen is not
able to as well but after these pawns
come off the board rook up here to d5
adding pressure on this pawn @ h5 if he
can go ahead and take this pawn off the
board three pawns to one with two passed
pawns it would be too much for
carjacking to overcome rook over here at
age six Magnus Carlsen says okay now is
the time to get my King involved into
the game and starts to push it up a
little bit and car yakin after King to
f6 resigns recognizing that King to g7
is going to be too difficult to hold on
to this material and he will end up
losing in an in-game not too long from
now so Magnus Carlsen with a you know
fantastic game got a little bit lucky
little his opponent did not find that
night to f2 that would have been pretty
pretty epic fail I think on his part but
kudos to the champion for for fighting
back in game Tim putting his opponent in
some really tough spots and coming out
with the victory so for those who are
kind of waiting for some fireworks you
we went through the first you know six
games with some pretty draws games no
neither side really looking to break
theory and do anything outside the norm
we're starting to see just that we're
starting to see some fireworks from both
sides so congratulations to Magnus
Carlsen the last two days are going to
be pretty exciting with you know we have
a day off and then we have karyakin
playing the white pieces in game 12 the
28th of November Magnus Carlsen playing
by pieces if they draw or they are equal
limits in points after that they will
take a day off and then come back with
ty Baker's on November 30th that is man
as Carlson's birthday it would be a nice
birthday present to win the World
Championship on there but hopefully guys
are enjoying the term I hopefully
enjoyed this game as well one of the
most exciting games I think really
exciting to see how Magnus Carlsen
maneuver
and actually got out with the victory so
thanks for watching and I'll see you all
in game number 11